researchers shows negative experiences
tend to affect us more strongly than
positive ones but a new book tells us
how we can actually turn that bad into
good the book is called the power of bad
how the negativity effect rules us and
how we can rule it instead of dwelling
on the negative we can use it to learn
important lessons like how to be a
better parent and argue less with a
partner New York Times contributing
columnist John Tierney co-wrote the book
and he is here with us welcome Happy New
Year Happy New Year this is a great way
to start the new year because we all
have this tendency to focus on the bad
you know even it even when there's a lot
of good in front of us why is that you
know our brains are wired to focus on
this it's called the negativity effect
there's this universal tendency for bad
events and bad emotions to affect this
more strongly than good one and there's
a reason it evolved because it helped
our ancestors survive threats but in its
game that can still be very useful I
mean you can harness the power of bad
for some really good purposes but we
just overdo it and we focus so much on
the negative that we miss all the good
things in our lives and we do B we'd be
happier we and more productive if we
learn to go on a low bad diet so we do
that by what when we make an error or
our Porter foot in our mouth and we we
we say okay that's that's a bad thing
but it's also an opportunity to get
better that's right it does teach you to
get better it's you know it's a great
power to learn from your mistakes you
know you learn more from failure than
from success and penalties are much more
effective in motivating workers and
students than prizes are you know but
when you do make that mistake it's not
enough to just do one good thing for you
know there's what we call the rule of
four that it takes typically for good
things to overcome one bad thing so if
you're late for one meeting you don't
make up for it by showing up early the
next time if you say one bad thing you
know you know aim to do four good things
to make up why is it for that seems like
a lot you know bad is is that much
stronger they and they've gotten that by
studying people's Diaries people's moods
and they see typically that you know
that's how it works and and the lesson
from that really is that we pride
ourselves on all the good things we do
for our friends for you know you know
going the extra mile yeah but what
really matters is what
we don't do you know it's that avoiding
bad is far more important than doing
good you know you get relatively little
extra credit by you know by going the
extra mile but you pay a big price for
falling short how do you deal with or
reconcile with avoiding the bad when
we're constantly on social media a
survey found that one in four Americans
have said negative comments online can
ruin their day you know what I mean that
can definitely happen but I mean that's
why we advises low bad diet the cure at
your social media feed so you're seeing
four good things really bad things and
you know and don't you know don't you
know don't read all the bad comments
about you you know when you read one bad
comment you know read four good ones to
come you talked about relationships in
the book and you share marriage advice
that Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg got from her mother-in-law
which was it helps sometimes to be a
little deaf right that is great advice
because researchers have found though
you know that marriages their success is
determined by how spouses handle
negativity you know and then the good
marriage they you know they learn to be
a little deaf they learned it you know
to ignore their other partners flaws
they do a little blind also I think
exactly you know and when something goes
wrong you either ignore it
or you give your spouse the benefit of
the doubt and if you do have to respond
you know stay calm and don't escalate
the conflict because bad emotions are so
powerful that you know a small
disagreement usually spirals into a
major fight so would you make that point
more broadly if you want to criticize
somebody but you don't want to add to
their negativity diet how do you do it
well you know start with the criticism
people often start with praise because
it's easier to do that but what happens
is then when you slip in the criticism
it's such a jolt to the brain yeah that
they just forget all the praise yes so
start with it bad stuff and then add
lots of good stuff later on I like that
I like it too one bad low bad diet one
bad comment can haunt you it really can
yeah yeah how do you find those four
good ones so on social media one piece
of advice we have is have somebody else
read your comments for you and tell you
you know and then give you the useful
ones and screen out the bad ones because
once you see the bad ones it just ruins
your day
alright john tierney thank you so much
the power of bad is on sale now
you